let's do some examples dividing
fractions let's say that i have negative
5 6
divided by
4 divided by positive 3 4. well we've
already talked about when you divide by
something it's the exact same thing as
multiplying by its reciprocal so this is
going to be the exact same thing as
negative 5 6
as negative 5 6
times
times the reciprocal of 3 4 which is 4
over 3. i'm just swapping the numerator
and the denominator so it's going to be
over 3. and we've already seen lots of
examples multiplying fractions this is
going to be the numerators times each
other so we're going to multiply
negative 5
times 4 i'll give the negative sign to
the 5 there so negative 5
times 4 let me do 4 in that yellow color
and then the denominator is 6 times 3.
times
times 3. now in the numerator here in
the numerator you see we have a negative
number you might already know that 5
times 4 is 20 and you just have to
remember that look we're multiplying a
negative times a positive we're
essentially going to have negative 5 4
times so negative 5 plus negative 5 plus
negative 5 plus negative 5 is negative
20.
so the numerator here is negative 20 and
the denominator here is 18. so we get 20
over 18 but we can simplify this both
the numerator and the denominator
they're both divisible by 2 so let's
divide them both by 2. so give myself a
little more space if we divide both the
numerator and the denominator by 2 just
to simplify this and i pick 2 because
that's the largest number that goes into
both of these it's the greatest common
divisor of 20 and 18.
20 divided by 2 is 10 and 18 divided by
2 is 9. so negative 5 6 divided by 3 4
is oh i have to be very careful here
it's negative
negative 10 9. just how we always learn
if you have a negative divided by a
positive if the signs are different then
you're going to get a negative value
let's do another example
let's say that i have
negative 4
negative 4 divided by
divided by
negative 1 half
negative
one half
so using the exact logic that we just
said we said hey look dividing by
something is equivalent to multiplying
by its reciprocal so this is going to be
equal to
negative four instead of writing as
negative 4 let me just write it as a
fraction so that we are clear what its
numerator is and what's denominator is
so negative 4 is the exact same thing as
negative 4 over 1 and we're going to
multiply
that
times the reciprocal of negative
one-half
the reciprocal of negative one-half is
negative two over one
negative two over one you could view it
as negative two over one or you could
use it as positive two over negative one
or you could use it as negative two
either way these are all the same value
and now we're ready to multiply notice
all i did here i rewrote the negative 4
just as negative 4 over 1. negative 4
divided by 1 is negative 4. and here for
the negative one-half since i'm
multiplying now i'm multiplying by its
reciprocal i've swapped the denominator
in the numerator or the i swap the
denominator and the numerator what was
the denominator is now the numerator
what was the numerator is now the
denominator and i'm ready to multiply
this is going to be equal to i gave both
the negative signs to the numerator so
it's going to be negative 4
negative 4 times
negative 2
in the numerator
and then in the denominator it's going
to be 1 times 1.
let me write that down 1
times
1 times 1.
and so this gives us
so we have a negative 4 times a negative
2. so it's a negative times a negative
so we get a positive value here and four
times two is eight so this is a positive
eight over
one and eight divided by one is just
equal to eight